hey guys it's Justine and today's
unboxing is going to be really fun I
have a bunch of Logitech designed for
Mac products and as you guys know I'm a
huge Mac fan so I'm really excited to
check these out we're gonna unbox and
then set them up at my new desk setup so
here's the things that we're going to be
checking out today this is the MX Master
3s for Mac it has a MAG speed scroll
wheel for hyper fast pixel precise
scrolling it has the perfect ergonomical
shape and it's ideally placed thumb
controls this comes in two colors the
space gray and pale gray these are also
both optimized for Mac OS and iPad OS
this is the Logitech Pebble m350 this
has an 18 month battery life it's also
got dual connectivity via Bluetooth with
silent productivity 90 noise reduction
with the same click feel it's also small
and portable so it's the perfect Mouse
for on the go this is the lift for mac
and I really like this mouse a lot it
gives you that natural handshake
position for all day Comfort it's a
great fit for small to medium hands it
has a Smart Wheel so you can scroll line
by line or you can fly through some tick
tocks at record Pace it's super quiet
and it's also optimized for Mac OS and
compatible with iPad this is a nice
complement to the pebble this is the
Multi-Device k380 for Mac you can type
on multiple devices you can connect up
to three compatible devices and switch
typing between them at the touch of a
button Mac OS iPad Os or even iOS it's
ultra quiet with laptop like typing and
this is the MX mechanical mini for Mac
this is a minimalist mechanical keyboard
of course with Bluetooth it has the
ultimate typing tactility and Next Level
Precision it has tactile quiet Keys long
lasting comfort with a balanced design
metal top case Mac optimized layout and
an adjustable typing angle this is also
compatible with the iPad it has easy
switching so you can connect up to three
devices and easily switch between them
USBC rechargeable so you can get up to
15 days or up to 10 months with
backlighting off with two color options
of space gray and pale gray you can
match these with one of your MX Master
3s's for Mac so let's open up these two
matching ones first this is ZK 380 and
this is the pebble mile I think we'll go
with the keyboard first
this blue color is so pretty wow look at
that
this is so nice so here's the three
selection buttons so you can pair
multiple devices to this and when you
want to switch to them one two three
easy as that this would be great for my
desk setup because I actually have two
computers set up and I also have an iPad
so with this I can just switch between
them and easily type away this is a nice
type I like the round Keys also get two
little AAA batteries in there I'm let's
open up this matching Pebble Mouse this
is so cute I just love this color blue
this knife is so sharp
oh I love this
love this all this is the perfect travel
Mouse
[Music]
this is also great this is where you can
store the USB connector like this has
the little USB receiver hidden away
inside of the mouse this is great
because I've had some mice previous to
this and I've actually lost the receiver
because it somehow just got misplaced so
I like that this has a nice little
secret hidden little spot for it so this
will also connect to Bluetooth or if you
have a device that isn't Bluetooth
compatible you can use this receiver and
you'll be able to connect to it like
look how good these look next to each
other they're so beautiful next up we
have the lift for Mac mouse look at this
one it's a vertical ergonomic Mouse it's
a part of the Ergo series by Logitech
foreign
look at this little dude it looks like a
little mountain I like that the buttons
are on the side we've got little
clickies here
scroll wheel oh this is awesome I'm just
visualizing myself working
I'm really excited to try this actually
because I've been editing a lot over the
past couple of days and like my arm I've
already had some issues obviously you
guys may know with this shoulder and
when I was like editing a lot in the way
that I kind of was sitting like my arm
started feeling weird and I got a little
nervous so I also feel like the way that
this
is like I'm not like my hand isn't like
this in like a normal Mouse position it
feels great like it just feels so comfy
this could be life-changing like
actually I've said things before are
life-changing but this actually feels
like this could be life-changing I can't
wait to try it you stay tuned because
we're going to be trying you out very
soon but we have two other mice that we
need to unbox these are both the MX
Master 3s for mac and we have them in
both colors we're gonna check those out
this also looks like it kind of has a
nice ergonomical feel now the same kind
of side style as this one
[Music]
wow that looks good too oh these are
exciting
foreign
also feels nice like my wrist is
elevated my thumb is very comfortably
placed over here on the other side oh
we've also got with these ones
some cables we've got a USBC cable
you can see on the bottom we've got a
little shiny metallic so they each match
the color so we've got this more silver
and this one's a little bit darker of a
silver these have a very similar color
to the MacBook colors so these match
kind of like the space gray and the
silver to the MacBooks even though
they're calling this the pale gray it
looks a little silver to me like you
can't even hear me clicking
The Click is very silent but if there is
enough tactile feedback so it actually
feels like you're clicking but you can't
hear it
the set of scroll wheel is also a click
which is nice and we've got two buttons
on the side in addition to this little
scroll wheel which I'm quite hyped about
this because I want to use that to
scroll my timeline left and right in
Final Cut love that
doing that all right I can't wait to try
these keyboards out got the two MX
mechanical minis now I love mechanical
keyboards but sometimes they're so loud
so I'm really excited to try this out
because it's a mechanical keyboard with
a quiet comfort of a not mechanical
keyboard and still that tactile feedback
so let's open them up and see what they
look like and type like
let's open them both at the same time
[Music]
okay well there's paper on them so let's
remove the paper
oh
these look so good oh yeah that's a nice
type I can't wait to get my little
fingers on that look at you look at you
and look how nice you look matched with
your little friend there and then if we
want to swap them out the pale gray look
at that wow this is a nice keyboard I
like it a lot it's a very nice type
we've even got the Emoji key which is
very important and we've got the three
keys right here to switch from different
devices so you can pair three different
Bluetooth devices right there one two
three nice
so everything is now in box now we're
going to take these over to my desk and
get them all set up and connected to
Bluetooth and test them out on multiple
devices and see how they type so it's
now time to test these out so I'm going
to start with the MX mechanical mini and
the MX Master 3s Mouse now I already
have these all paired up we're set we're
ready to go and so far I started doing a
little editing before we started rolling
and I am so excited about this so let me
show you how great this is for scrolling
in the timeline so here's all of our
footage like I can just go like this
look at this I'm still scrolling look
hands off and I can just go poop stop I
wish that I would have had this mouse
when I was editing this video because I
can scroll so fast through so much
footage
oh this is incredible I also like that
they have programmable buttons so I can
actually set these up to be shortcut
keys in Final Cut Pro another thing that
I like is it has this horizontal scroll
so when I'm scrolling my timeline I'd
like to be able to scroll left and right
so not only can I do that but I can also
scroll up and down my hand feels very
chill it's very relaxed this is a very
comfortable fit it fits on my palm
perfectly I also like that it has a
little area for my thumb so I can kind
of just rest it here so a lot of times
when you're using a mouse like this is
just dragging this it has a little arm
rest but for your thumb I started
working on this document and I opened it
up and I oh I was so sad it's a novel
three Tails I didn't write this but I'm
going to change a few things a novel The
Story of cbtl coming bird babies so if
you guys missed this I had a hummingbird
nest and the hummingbird babies we were
watching them on a live stream and they
unfortunately didn't make it and it was
so incredibly traumatizing so this is me
writing the novel about their life
it's mechanical but it's not loud like a
normal mechanical keyboard I had to film
them I got my camera out and I set up a
live stream I also like that this is
formatted for Mac it has the command
apple key so we kind of know where we
are we feel at home with this keyboard
designed for Mac we love to see it
incoming lift now this one is so
interesting to me because it's so not
traditional of a mouse shape and this
can also be connected to three different
Bluetooth items we've got one two and
three so that will change depending upon
which device you have it connected to so
I'm gonna set up number one and we're
gonna have that wow this is such a
unique feel like I've never used a mouse
like this before and I love that it has
the track wheel right here on the side
and we've got the two left and right
buttons and the other two configurable
buttons it's such a comfortable feel oh
look at this one so here's our Pebble
m350 and our k380 keyboard now something
that I didn't test out on the previous
ones but they also have this capability
is you have this one two and three and
up here you can use those to switch
between different devices so I'm going
to connect my iPhone iPad and my
computer and show you how easy it is to
switch between the three so I have the
keyboard all hooked up to three
different devices so number one is just
going to make a new document here just a
blank document now number one is hooked
up to my computer look at that I'm
typing hello I am typing it is a nice
type okay great now I'm going to switch
to my iPhone here we go hello I am now
typing on my iPhone okay number three
get ready get ready now I am typing on
my iPad if we want to go back to our Mac
click number one and guess what we're
back on the MacBook I really like this
keyboard and mouse combination because
it is so small and portable so this is
something that I could easily throw into
my suitcase take it with me even put it
in my backpack because it is so small
and thin I also really like these Keys
like the little round circles but it's
such a fun type this is very similar to
some of the previous ones that they've
had so I'm really glad to see that they
have this new color in the mouse to
match thank you guys so much for
watching I hope you guys enjoyed this
video I'll put a link in the description
to all of the keyboards and the mice
that I talked about today if you guys
have any questions feel free to leave
them in the comments and I will see you
in my next video if you haven't already
please subscribe also hit the Bell to be
notified when I post new videos and I'll
see you guys in the next one bye
[Music]